harvest time in Spain should be a time
for celebration for olive growers this
year it's a time of anxiety as they
shake down the trees the US is imposing
a new 25% import tax on their olive oil
attacks that could decimate this fifth
generation family business unable to
compete with cheaper imports the vessels
that are carrying Spanish olive oil to
the States haven't even reached their
destination so what's going to happen
they were sold before these tariffs were
a threat so putting a 25% margin on top
of this will kill our competitiveness
Spain is the world's largest producer of
olive oil exports to the US are worth
440 million dollars but those working in
the fields have not had it easy lately
last year's record harvest caused olive
oyl's purchase price to plummet by 44%
and more and more countries are planting
their own olive groves joining the
market piling the tariffs on top of this
could lead to collapse
last week thousands of Olive workers
took to the streets of Madrid demanding
the EU push back on the new tariffs and
prop up the industry they say they don't
understand why an agreement that
politicians had with Airbus should
penalize their products will just be a
physical sector Agricola we think is
very unfair because the agricultural
sector acts like a monetary exchange for
other industries that have nothing to do
with the sector in this case it's the
aeronautical industry which has nothing
to do with us while olive producers are
already feeling the squeeze around eight
hundred and forty five million dollars
worth of Spain's agricultural exports
will face US tariffs the EU warns it
will retaliate with its own import taxes
if they win their parallel case against
the US next year it all has the makings
of a tit-for-tat
trade war charlie Angela al Jazeera
let's discuss this further now with
Henry Kerr whose economics editor at The
Economist and he joins us from London
via Skype Henry's nice to have you on
the program it hardly seems fair does it
that you know olive oil exporters or
exporters of whiskey or exporters of
suits or whatever it might be that have
nothing to do with Boeing or Airbus
should be caught in the crossfire here
well yes I can understand why that
people involved might might see it that
way the strange thing about these
tariffs is that they have gone through
the WTO insofar as the WTO green-lighted
the Trump administration to impose them
having made a judgment on the case about
the subsidies to Airbus so I can see how
the people involved might rightly think
they're unrelated to that case but they
have gone through a system external to
the US and a way some of the other
tariffs that been imposed by Washington
haven't
well after that WTO ruling of course
there was a lot of discussion even
coming from the United States that said
look we'd rather find a negotiated
settlement here and that those tack that
those subsidies should be withdrawn from
from Europe when it comes to Airbus but
why didn't a negotiated process succeed
and
have been necessary to wrap this up now
well it's a very long running dispute
and of course it goes both ways so it's
all very well for the u.s. to say that
they'd be happy if the subsidies the
Airbus were wound up but of course the
European Union wants America to provide
less support to Boeing there's no doubt
really that both sides are subsidizing
at these domestic industries and it's
entirely possible that the WTO will rule
that the EU is allowed to impose tariffs
on American goods - the only thing that
might hold that up is that America is
holding up nominations to the WTO's
Appeals Board so because if that's
gumming up the WTO a bit that might get
in the way but we're not for that most
people expect that the WTO would make an
equivalent judgement in the opposite
direction it's the idea that this is a
sort of small dispute that could be
negotiated away easily is wrong it's
very long-running and it has multiple
parts and Henry if that happens if the
WTO and it did rule in favor of as you
said it ruled in favor of the year of
the US tariffs if the WTO said okay now
Europe can impose their own we're into a
tit-for-tat trade war aren't we and what
are the the consequences of that more
broadly
well we yes we would be of course the
purpose of the WTO procedures is to try
and constrain tit-for-tat trade wars to
try and make sure that all tariff
responses are proportionate the
complaints that are brought I think that
bigger concern here is that we're
operating at a time now where the Trump
administration is perfectly willing to
circumvent the WTO so although in this
case it has been approved there's still
this outstanding matter of whether
America might impose tariffs on European
cars for instance in the name of
national security that's still basically
an option available to the Trump
administration and the president has on
multiple occasions attacked European
trade policy he's annoyed with the
European Central Bank for its loose
monetary policy which he sees as keeping
the euro too weak and so on so I think
the question is whether this spills
beyond the matter of aircraft making and
into a brawl
trade dispute that's not constrained
within the WTO procedures and all of
this of course at a time of slowing
growth in the ongoing trade war with
China as well Henry thank you so much
for giving us your time thank you thank
you